la ciudad rusa de bélgorod amaneció con
el sonido de fuertes explosiones que
dañaron a 11 edificios de apartamentos a
39 casas particulares y que destruyó
completamente a una casa según el
gobernador de la región los residentes
atestiguan de la fuerza del impacto el
techo se derrumbó y la bola de fuego no
me di cuenta de la bola de fuego porque
ya estaba histérica levanté a mi hijo y
nos arrastramos justo sobre el cristal
así como si estuviéramos nadando salimos
a la calle yo me estaba levantando en
ese momento y fue lanzado hacia la
puerta por la ola explosiva los
cristales de las ventanas salieron
volando mi espalda sufrió un ligero
corte sin rossi por estas explosiones
serían producto de los desechos de tres
misiles que según moscú fueron
disparados por ucrania y derivados por
los sistemas de defensa aérea rusos
quiero enfatizar que este ataque con
misiles fue planeado y llevado a cabo
deliberadamente contra civiles en
ciudades rusas
los activos de defensa aérea rusos
destruyeron en el aire los tres misiles
balísticos que estaban equipados con
ojiva racimo y fueron lanzados por los
nacionalistas ucranianos contra el goro
desde el inicio de la ofensiva de
músculo en ucrania rusia acusa o varias
veces a las fuerzas ucranianas de haber
efectuado ataques en territorio ruso
especialmente en esta región de bélgorod
a sólo unos kilómetros de la frontera
con ucrania